started going to community college so I
went to Santa Monica Community College
good school by the way yeah it's a great
school it has the best transfer rate of
any Community College in the country I
feel like I got a better education at
SMC than UCLA yes because it's more
desirable to be a professor to
communicate yes and at UCLA you have to
be doing research it's a research
University and so a lot of the
professors there you know are writing
their own books in the English
literature Department working on their
Theses that sort of thing at a community
college they are there for the students
and guess what it was seven dollars yes
seven dollars seven dollars for a
semester yeah how there's a California